.
Valérie-Micaela Bain.
- La pression aura finalement eu
raison de Hockey Canada.
Scott Smith, président et
l'organisation, a pris le chemin
de la porte, suivi des membres
du conseil d'administration qui
ont démissionné en bloc.
à ce que de nouveaux dirigeants
soient en mesure d'encadrer
les joueurs pour en faire
non seulement de bons athlètes,
PASCALE ST-ONGE
ministre fédérale des Sportsdess
- Ce à quoi les gens s'attendent
au-delà des belles paroles,
le terrain.
- L'orga'enlisait
depuis des mois sans démontrer
de signes d'imputabilité pour
les scandales d'allégations
d'agressions sexuelles au fil
des ans.
Depuis une semaine, la chute d:
désaveu des fédérations
provinciprovinciprovinciales, pe
commanditaires d'envergures et
démission de la présidente p
d'administration à la suited'unt
un comité parlementaire aux
communes.ait cavalier
seul. Le dossier est loin d'être
clos, selon le député du Bloc
québécois Sébastien Lemire.
- Il y a toujours la nécessité
de poursuivre notre travail,
notamment celle d'une enquête
sur comment Hockey Canada gère
essus de plaintes
comment il l'a fait par le passé
et comment il va c.
- Les prhaines semaines vont
être déterminants sur l'avenir
et la confiance qu'on peut avoir
dans Hockey Canada version 2.0.
Est-ce ucomplètement? Est-ce qut
capables encore de faire affaire
avec la même organisation?
- La fédération de hockey de
l'Ontario qualifie
d'extrêmement important;
elle juge que la confiance doit
les Canadiens sur et hors de
la glace
Hockey Québec juge qu'il est
essentiel que les futurs
gestes concrets pour effectuer
des changements engements engemn
termes de respect, d'intégrité
et de culture.
- Il faut un engagil,
de la part de la haute directiot
en faire la promotion.
- C'est démission
elles pour faire r
C'est moi tu ne crest
un pas dans la bonne direction.
Mais elle ne compte pas rétablir
son soutien financier tant q